[Musique]
sous le capot c'est plus des chevaux
c'est carrément des lions la petite
dernière de chez peugeot la 306 maxi a
impressionné tout le monde sur les
routes de colombier-fontaine même le
pilote le plus par rapport à l'ancienne
c'est l'un des moteurs un moteur ou
dernier on est à 2 102 115 chevaux là on
à 255 plus le plus important c'est le
couple moteur on a un couple moteur de
25 kg
m alors que les dernières années que 22
donc c'est ça le plus important les
essais ont rassuré le staff compétition
du lion 7 306 devrait faire son entrée
en compétition lors de la troisième
épreuve de la saison en alsace avec pour
objectif le championnat de france
l'objectif c'est d'abord mais plus
modestement championnat de france allait
se battre avec les gros bonnets et puis
également notre concurrent direct
renault qui a effectivement déjà fait
naître sa s'acquitte car a priori sur le
plan technique la 306 maxi a toutes ses
chances reste maintenant aux pilotes à
éviter de finir dans le décor comme
aujourd'hui
[Musique]